katia bonjour quel est le programme de
ce deuxième jour de procès et bien
aujourd'hui pour cette deuxième journée
de procès historique la cour va procéder
à l'audition de sept des onze prévenus
donc voyons n'entrent dans le vif du
sujet ils sont jugés pour complicité
dans la préparation d'un acte terroriste
ou encore association de malfaiteurs il
y aura également l'audition de quelques
témoins et des enquêteurs de
personnalité
alors ce procès c'est un procès sous
haute surveillance avec énormément de
forces policières ici de très nombreux
contrôles pour accéder aux quatre salles
qui permettent la d'assister au procès
ou alors de le suivre des centaines de
personnes sont présentes pour le sur
parties civiles à des témoins évidemment
avocat presse hier derrière les masques
on a pu repérer rice coco patrick peloux
charlie-hebdo ou encore lassana bâti le
magasinier de l'hyper cacher évidemment
des victimes toujours traumatisés par ce
drame à l'arrière vous le disiez le
procès s'est ouvert avec des éléments
techniques l'appel des parties civiles
l'appel des témoins et puis l'après-midi
régis de jorna et ses assesseurs ont lu
le rapport luck la chronologie des faits
les charges ont rappelé les charges et
aujourd'hui les auditions vont permettre
d'affiner pour comprendre le degré
d'implication des personnes qui ont aidé
à les frères kwasi ou encore à mehdi
coulibaly sachant que les victimes et
leurs proches ont toujours énormément de
questions sans réponse 4' pique nique en
direct du palais de justice de paris on
vous retrouve un bien sûr lors de nos
prochaines éditions pour suivre ce
procès historique